along with cats and gowns college
graduation comes with a reality check
for millions of Americans a staggering
burden of student loan debt the average
debt is 37 000 but many owe six figures
and for most paying it off is a daunting
task graduates at one small California
College learned what it means to have
all and I mean all of their student debt
wiped out Mark Strassman caught up with
some of them a year later
two gifts have shaped Kayla Medina
villanueva's life her artistic talent
and the unlikely kindness of a stranger
I'm still a little bit in shock when I
think about it
May of last year commencement exercises
at Otis College of Art and Design in Los
Angeles the moment when dreams collided
with debt for grads like Kayla minor
contemporary clay with honors when you
graduated from Otis how much did you owe
I believe it was around
thousand dollars like where am I gonna
work how am I gonna be able to pay this
off sometimes it really pays to listen
to the commencement speaker I had the
opportunity to attend Otis summer of art
when I was 15 enrolling in graphic
design and drawing in this case
billionaire Evan Spiegel the founder of
snap Inc you don't need me to tell you
you're gonna do amazing things you've
got everything you need to pursue your
dreams everything maybe but a winning
lottery ticket what followed was pretty
darn close but now we have one more gift
for the class of 2022. and I told my
friend what are they going to pay our
student loans joking around nope no joke
Evan and Miranda through their Spiegel
Family Fund have made the largest single
gift in the history of Otis College
their gift will enable you to repay your
student loans
my job dropped I was like what Kayla's
classmate 23 year old suhei Elias what
just happened I just said oh my God
[Applause]
not Pennies from Heaven but Millions
from Evan the special gift from Spiegel
and his wife model and businesswoman
Miranda Kerr totaled more than 10
million dollars
Otis president Charles hirschorn people
are crying it's making me cry
we're right in front of me and they're
all gasping a year later Sue hay is
still gasping and free to pursue her
dream painting I might have like had to
put my dream aside and just like focus
on the loans but now I'm able to you
know just do what I love Kayla sells her
ceramics in our shows but she wants to
pay her gift forward and teach art in
her LA Mexican American Community would
that have been remotely possible if you
had a student loan to pay off no the
bills would be the ones kind of deciding
what I did after now it's me deciding
Hirsch hornhub Spiegel's gift will
inspire other philanthropists that is a
real you know it's like tying an arm
behind their back and philanthropy is
one magic wand there are no magic wands
yeah but I think investing in students
is a good investment Sue hay Elias
promises investing in her will pay off
if Evan spiega watches this story what
would you like to say to him just thank
you just thank you thank you thank you
it's it's a blessing why so emotional
it's my mom she passed away four years
ago
and she she would be so proud
turns out giving is also a fine art
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman in Los
Angeles
it's a great Mark Strassman piece uh
Eric Spiegel and his wife it's a
wonderful thing they did uh very much
folks you know I do think about how the
folks in the class behind that class
feel the class ahead of that class and I
think about the overall problem of the
cost of college and how big it is you
know thank God for one billionaire but
if only there were a way to solve the
larger issue it just weighs so heavy I
know students
right yes what would we do without
billions what would we do without
billionaires who would solve these
issues it makes such a huge difference
though especially as you're starting out
your careers yes if you are just so
encumbered with all these student loan
debts you know what else I recommend
trade school straight away no debt
you'll make 100K a year and you will
never be unemployed this is why college
enrollment has been going around for
five six years in a row because that is
not a good bargain the price is college
thank you Tony we're to wisdom there